Ich habe nur etwas zu sagen.
Guten Tag, Sie sind mein Name.
Ich habe das aufgenommen, das ich mit Ihnen führte.
Sind Sie damit entgegen?
Ja, gerne.
Ich habe eine Beziehung mit Ihnen.
Ich würde gerne am Anfang meine Argime praten.
Wie heißen Sie?
Hallo, ich heiße Andrea Benzema.
Andrea?
Ja, das ist mein Vorname und mein Nachname ist Benzema.
Wie man es ausspricht?
Können Sie Ihren Nachnamen...
Ich darf Ihnen sagen, ja.
Ben, S-E-M-E Richard.
Benzema, okay.
Was sind Sie, General Geborgen, Frau Benzema?
Erster Juni 1961.
Wie alt bin ich?
51.
Nein.
Ich weiß nicht, 61 glaube ich.
61.
Wie groß sind Sie, Frau Benzema?
Ich bin 1,77 m.
Ich bin 61.
Wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 1,70 m groß und 81 kg schwer.
81 kg schwer.
Was für Sie, Frau Benzema? Was kenne ich für Sie?
Ich habe Luftnot.
Seit wann haben Sie Luftnot?
Ich habe Luftnot schon 14 Tage.
Schon 14 Tage.
Sind Ihre Schmerzen langsam oder plus die Begüren?
Ich habe keine Schmerzen, ich habe nur Luftnot.
Luftnot, sorry, Luftnot.
Eigentlich fing das auf einmal an vor 14 Tagen.
Plötzlich?
Ja.
Ist Ihre Luftnot da oder?
Ist es die ganze Zeit schlecht?
Ist es im Laufe der Zeit schlechter geworden?
Nein, nicht dass ich gleich.
So wie vor 14 Tagen.
Seit 14 Tagen.
Gibt es eine bestimmte Ausrüstung für Ihre Luftnot?
Wie meine ich?
Zum Beispiel nach der köpelschen Belastung oder nach der bestimmten Essen, Mahlzeit.
Sie meinen, ob das belastungsabhängig ist oder ob das Mahlzeiten abhängig ist?
Ja, ich meine.
Oder ob das lageabhängig ist oder ob es bewegungsabhängig ist?
Man kann immer sagen abhängig.
Ihr seid Ihre Beschwerden Mahlzeiten abhängig oder belastungsabhängig?
Nein, nein, sind Sie nicht.
Ich bin natürlich, weil ich diese Luftnot habe, kann ich nicht mehr so gut treppensteigen.
Gut treppensteigen?
Hab ich Sie auch früher ennische Becher verdient?
Nein, habe ich nicht gehabt.
Ich fahre sogar Fahrrad.
Könnese imano fahren, fahren?
Nein, jetzt nicht mehr.
Jetzt nicht mehr.
Wie viele Stufen können Sie früher steigen?
Ich wohne in einem Einfamilienhaus mit einem Stockwerk und das habe ich normalerweise ganz normal hoch und runter geschafft.
Aber jetzt geht das nicht mehr.
Okay, muss es ja eine Pause machen?
Ja, jetzt geht es nicht mehr so gut.
Ich mache immer zwei Stufen.
Ich mache ständig Pause.
Haben Sie auch Lust?
Ja, so ein Reiz, ja, so ein Reiz-Husten habe ich.
Aber ich habe vor 14 Tagen noch kein Husten gehabt.
Das ist jetzt in den letzten drei Tagen habe ich immer mehr Husten gekriegt.
Haben Sie auch Auswurf?
Jetzt ein bisschen.
Wie ist Ihr Auswurf?
Ich meine, ist es schleimig?
Wie ist die Farbe?
Also, Auswurf ist immer schleimig?
Wie ist der Schleim?
Wie ist die Farbe oder was für eine Farbe? Grün oder Geld?
Ich habe das Gefühl, dass es etwas Geldpflicht ist jetzt.
Es ist Geldpflicht.
Wann treten, ja, Sie haben gesagt, dass es bleibt,
Ihre Beschwerden dauerhaft.
Aber ist es Ihnen aufgefallen, dass Sie eher in der Nacht mehr Beschwerden haben?
Nein, nein, ich habe immer Luftnoten seit 14 Tagen.
Das ist ein bisschen mehr geworden.
Ich habe jetzt auch ein bisschen Husten.
Und wenn ich nachts liege, kann ich natürlich, weil ich Luftnot habe, nicht mehr so gut schlafen.
Können Sie vielleicht liegen?
Nein.
Vorher schon, vor 14 Tagen habe ich ganz normal geschlafen, jetzt nicht mehr.
Okay.
Mussten Sie mit den vielen Kissen?
Jetzt ja.
Zwei, drei Kissen, wie viele Kissen mussten Sie benutzen?
So viele Kissen habe ich gar nicht zu Hause.
Ich versuche einfach nur, noch ein Kissen zu nehmen, damit ich etwas höher liegen kann.
Mussten Sie wegen Ihren Luftnoten in der Nacht aufwachen?
Ich kann ja gar nicht richtig schlafen.
Ich schlafe ja gar nicht richtig.
Wegen Ihren Atmungnoten.
Genau.
Haben Sie dicke Beine?
Ja, Frau Doktor, das ist mir aufgefallen.
Das rechte Bein ist dick geworden.
Rechte Beine ist dick geworden.
Gibt es auch Farbeförderung in Ihrem rechten Bein?
Das ist mir nicht aufgefallen.
Ist Ihr rechte Bein geschwollen?
Was meinen Sie denn mit Farbveränderung?
Gerötet, geschwollen.
Geschwollen ist das, habe ich ja gesagt, das ist dicker, das rechte Bein.
Aber gerötet ist es nicht.
Gerötet nicht.
Oder glänzt sie geworden.
Okay.
Hab es nicht gemacht, am ehembrechsten Bein, beim Durukun?
Wenn ich auftrete, ja.
Wenn ich gehe, tut es weh.
Hab es nicht gemacht, am ehembrechsten Bein?
Nein, in der Wade.
Nein, gleich.
Hat sich nicht viel verälernert.
Frau Benzema, haben Sie Fieber?
Nein.
Nein, kein Fieber.
Fühlen Sie sich fieblich? Nein.
Nein, das tue ich nicht.
Wie ist Ihr Appetit?
Wissen Sie, wenn man Luftnot hat, kann man nicht gut essen.
Entschuldigen Sie bitte.
Aber vor 14 Tagen war mein Appetit noch gut.
Okay.
Sie haben mir gesagt, deswegen haben Sie nicht gut geschlafen können.
Haben Sie auch Übelkeit, Erbrechen, Sortbränen?
Okay.
Hab ich nicht.
Leider Sie unter Verstückung oder Durchfall?
Nein.
Ist es Ihnen aufgefallen, dass die
Farbe ihres Urins oder Irrschtuss verandert hat?
Ich habe ganz normalen Urin und ganz normalen braunen Stuhlgang.
Okay, gut.
Frau Benzema, leider Sie an krönchen Erkrankungen?
Was meinen Sie mit krönchen Erkrankungen?
Wie ist Zuckerkrankheit, Bluthochdruck?
Ja.
Seit wann haben Sie Bluthochdruck?
Das habe ich schon so 10 Jahre.
Nehmen Sie Medikamente dagegen?
Ist das schon mit krönchen Erkrankungen?
Ja, ich nehme Kandesatan 16 abends ein.
Dann nehme ich Bisoprol,
2,5 Milligramm morgens und abends ein.
Und am Lodipin, 5 Milligramm morgens.
Ansonsten sind Sie gesund, haben Sie noch weitere Erkrankungen?
Ansonsten fällt mir jetzt nichts ein.
Ja, momentan, ja.
Aber wo das bei Ihnen andere Krankheiten festgestellt hat?
Nein.
Sind Sie schon einmal bei einem Kardiologen gewesen?
Nein, warum?
Wurden alle diese Medikamente von Ihrem Hausarzt aufgeschrieben?
Ja.
Die Medikamente sind alle von meinem Hausarzt.
Sind Sie schon einmal operiert worden?
Entschuldigung, nicht vom Hausarzt aufgeschrieben,
sondern vom Hausarzt verschrieben.
Aufschreiben ist nur auf Papier schreiben.
Verschreiben ist Rezept, ne?
Sind Sie schon einmal operiert worden?
Nein.
Sind Sie schon einmal stationär behandelt worden?
Nein, eigentlich bin ich wirklich gerundet gewesen bis jetzt.
Okay, gut.
Wie sieht es aus mit Ihrem Blutdruck?
Ist das in Ordnung?
Ja, eigentlich schon.
Also nachdem ich diese Medikamente jetzt habe,
ist mein Blutdruck eigentlich ganz in Ordnung.
Ich messe mein Blutdruck dreimal am Tag und schreibe es auch auf.
Der höchste Wert ist 145.
Ja, sehr gut.
Okay.
Frau Werner, sind bei Ihnen Allergie bekannt?
Ja, ich habe eine Jodallergie und eine Nickelallergie.
Wie ausserzt es sich?
Bitte?
Die Jodallergie.
Bei der Jodallergie ist es ganz schlimm.
Bei der Nickelallergie habe ich Ausschlag.
Bei der Nickelallergie habe ich überall am Körper.
Jetzt wird es rot und ich gehe keine Luft mehr.
Okay.
Haben Sie Jodallergie im Krankenhaus erlebt?
Jodallergie.
Bei einer Untersuchung.
Da habe ich nämlich Kontrastmittel gekriegt.
Da ist eine Computertomographie gemacht worden.
Mit Kontrastmittel.
Und dann habe ich reagiert am ganzen Körper.
Dann wurde es im Krankenhaus behandelt.
Genau.
Was für eine Untersuchung war das?
Damals.
Die Untersuchung.
Ja.
Also es ist so,
dass die eine Computertomographie gemacht haben damals.
Von Lunge und Bauch.
Weil ich damals,
das ist aber ein paar Jahre her,
da habe ich viel Gewicht abgenommen.
Dann wollten die wissen, warum.
Und dann haben die einen CT gemacht.
Von Lunge und Bauch.
Wo sie irgendwas festgestellt hat.
Die waren sich nicht ganz sicher.
Die haben gesagt, das muss noch mal kontrolliert werden.
Aber ich bin dann nicht mehr gegangen zum kontrollieren.
Und ich weiß auch nicht mehr genau, was das war.
Die haben gesagt, da ist etwas,
das kontrolliert werden muss.
In einem halben Jahr noch mal.
Aber wissen Sie, das war bestimmt nichts.
Ich bin nicht mehr gegangen.
Okay.
Für viele Jahre war es.
5, 6, 7 so ungefähr.
Aber ihr Gewichtabnahme ist aus.
Ich habe danach nicht mehr abgenommen.
Jetzt ist es so.
Ausgeblich.
Jetzt ist mir eigentlich so ganz gut.
Ich ess jetzt nicht mehr, nicht so viel.
Aber ich denke, das reicht.
Okay.
Ich brauche ein paar Reformen über Ihre Gewohnheiten.
Rachen Sie?
Ja.
Wie viel ist der Redenamt?
Eine Packung seit 30 Jahren.
Okay.
Trinken Sie Alkohol?
Beigelegenheit.
Beigelegenheit, nein.
Nur bei bestimmten Anlässen.
Hochzeitsfeier, Geburtstagsfeier.
Okay.
Also man kann sagen, gelegentlich oder Beigelegenheit.
Geht beides.
Gerne.
Bitte nehmen Sie diese Frage.
Ich habe eine kleine Frage.
Haben Sie Kontakt mit den Trocken?
Nein.
Noch nie?
Noch ein Minuten.
Wie ist das an dem Gespräch abläuft?
Ja.
Wir müssen sich bei allen nur noch eine Minute, dann läuft es ab.
Okay.
Wie ist Ihr Familienstand?
Ich bin verheiratet.
Haben Sie Kinder?
Ich habe drei Kinder.
Sind Sie gesund?
Ja, meine Kinder sind Gott sei Dank gesund.
Was machen Sie von mir?
Ich bin Architektin.
Architektin.
Ich arbeite von zu Hause wegen diesem Lockdown.
Okay, gut.
Gibt es in Ihrer Familie wichtige Krankheiten,
von denen ich wissen sollte?
Mir fällt nichts besonderes ein.
Hat es noch Leben in der Realität?
Nein, es sind beide gestorben.
Woher sind die gestorben?
Natürlicher Tod.
Die sind alt geworden.
Okay.
Das haben wir gesprächt beendet.
Und jetzt?
Hast du Gesprächsbänder, natürlich.
20 Minuten ist abgelaufen.
20 Minuten sind abgelaufen.
Eine Minute ist abgelaufen.
Sollen wir anfangen mit der Ersatzgespräch?
Okay.
War das jetzt alles an Fragen?
Ja.
Okay.
Dann machen wir das.
Haben die andere Fragen?
Stört Sie das, wenn ich mein Tee trink?
Stört Sie das?
Okay.
Haben die andere Fragen?
Haben Sie oft Herzklopfen, Stolpern oder Rasen?
Nach türbärischer Berastung?
Jetzt? Ja, seit 14 Tagen.
Vorher nicht.
Sind Sie deswegen schon bei einem anderen Teil?
Ich dachte, das geht von selbst weg.
Ich bin zu Hause geblieben.
Ich war noch nicht beim Arzt.
Haben Sie dabei eine EKG?
Ich war nicht beim Arzt.
Was fällt Ihnen schwerer ein oder aus zu atmen?
Das weiß ich nicht.
Einatmen fällt mir schwerer.
Okay.
Vielen Dank.
Haben Sie das?
Ich habe eine Frage.
Sind Sie gereist?
Perreist.
Nein, bin ich nicht.
Und derzeit arbeiten Sie daheim?
Wie viele Stunden sitzen Sie beim Tisch?
Ich sitze viel am Schreibtisch.
Ich sitze schon viel.
Ich muss keine Hausarbeit machen.
Ich sitze am Schreibtisch und mache meine Sachen.
Träben Sie Sport?
Nein, ich bin vorher viel fahrradgefahren.
Aber das geht jetzt nicht mehr.
Seitdem ich die Luftnot habe, kann ich das nicht mehr machen.
Sind Sie gegen Corona ausständig?
Ich bin nicht.
Ich bin gegen Covid dreimal geimpft sogar.
Hatten Sie vor 14 Tagen eine Lungeninfektion?
Das ist eine gründliche pulmonale Infekt.
Ich verstehe, krippale Infekt, vor 14 Tagen?
Nein, habe ich nicht gehabt.
Hatten Sie einen Unfall?
Jemand hat mir gefragt, ob Sie einen Unfall hatten.
Ach, hier im Chat, da guck ich gar nicht drauf genau.
Ich trinke ausreichend, ja, ich hatte keinen Unfall, keinen Trauma.
Wegen dem Bein oder was?
Wahrscheinlich, wegen dem Bein fragen die.
Nein, nicht, dass ich mich gestoßen habe, gestürzt bin.
Nein, ich kann mich nicht erinnern.
Eigentlich trinke ich gut, ich trinke mindestens 1,5 Liter,
aber ich gucke, dass ich immer 2 Liter trinke am Tag.
Okay, soll ich anfangen?
Wenn Fragen beendet sind, gerne.
Ihr seid betrags 20 Min.
Bitte.
Okay.
20 Minuten.
Ich habe eine neue Patientin aufgenommen.
Darf ich eine Patientin Ihnen erforscht haben?
Gerne.
Danke.
Andrea Benzema ist eine sexy jährige Patientin, die sich bei uns wegen
vor 14 Tagen aufgetretenen, aufgetretenen, vor 14 Tagen
bestehenden, dauernd, an dauernden, diesmal vorgestattet hat.
Stopp, das war grammatikalisch falsch.
Am Anfang alles super perfekt.
Andrea Benzema ist eine 61 jährige Patientin, die sich bei uns
wegen, das war auch alles richtig, wegen war auch alles richtig.
Wo muss es weitergehen?
Wegen plötzlich aufgetretenen, Atembeschwerden oder wegen plötzlich
aufgetretenen, näher, Duspne, die Duspne-Tschönke oder wegen
plötzlich aufgetretenen Luftnot, die seit 14 Tagen anhält, bei uns
vorstellt oder bei uns vorgestellt hat.
Das geht so.
Entschuldigung.
Danke.
Wegen seit 14 Tagen bestehender, wegen plötzlich aufgetretener
Luftnot, die seit 14 Tagen anhält.
Luftnot, die seit 4 Tagen anhält, vorgestellt hat.
Okay.
Die Patientin hat berichtet, dass sie wegen der Duspne nicht richtig
schlafen kann und sie seit 3 Tagen außer Danbusten mit
gellblich Schuput umhat.
Stopp.
Entschuldigung.
Danke.
Die Patientin hat außer Danbusten nicht wegen der Duspne nicht
wegen der Duspne nicht wegen der Duspne nicht wegen der
Duspne nicht wegen der Duspne nicht v.a.
mit gellblich Schuput umhat.
Eine trockene Huste an gelblichem Sputum geht nicht.
Was ist trockener Husten? Trockener Husten heißt kein Sputum. Ich habe gesagt, das reizt so. Ich habe
nicht gesagt trockener Husten. Produktiver Husten. Jetzt ist es produktiv, weil sie auch ein bisschen
Sputum hat. Sagen einfach, dass sie Husten hat mit Schleimauswurf, der gelblich ist oder so,
mit gelblichem Schleimauswurf oder mit gelblichem Schleif oder mit gelbem Schleim. Kann man
alles sagen? Ja. Bei drei Tagen hat sie Husten mit gelben Schleim. Wir sagen immer Schleimauswurf,
aber unterschiedlich. Sie kann nicht flach liegen und sie muss mit dem Kissen in der Nacht
schlafen. Sie hat nächtliche Düsbne und die Patientin berichtet, dass sie außerhalb der Patientin angegeben
das Rechtenbein dicker geworden ist. Sehr gut. Die Pajarzeichnung ist positiv. Haben Sie das
überprüft? Ich habe noch nicht die Patientin körperlich unterzut. Darauf darf man sich aber nicht verlassen.
Pajarzeichen positiv dürfen Sie erst sagen, wenn Sie es selber überprüft haben. Das ist auch nicht Pajarzeichen, das ist Homers. Aber Zeichen erst sagen, dass es positiv ist, wenn Sie es selber überprüft haben.
Du kannst sagen, dass die Patientin die Anlage der Beine nicht verabschiedet hat. Die Patientin hat klaxenlose, körperliche Belastungsbedingte Luftnot.
Die vegetative Anlage ist unabhängig. Als Vorerkrankung hat die Patientin arterielle Hypertonis zu sein.
Die Patientin hat eine Erlegerung, die allergieöser sich durchgesammelt hat. Frau Benzema ist eine Raucherin. Sie raute eine Plakon seit 30 Jahren. Sie trinkt keine Alkohol. Sie trinkt Alkohol nur zur Bestintern anlassend und hat keinen Kontakt mit den Drogen.
Die Patientin ist verheiratet, hat drei Gesunde Kinder, sie ist Architektur von Beruf. Es gibt keine Auffälligkeiten bei ihrer Familienanlage.
Die Patientin hat auch erwähnt, dass es eine Untersuchung vor sechs Jahren bei ihr durchgeführt wurde. Es war eine Bauchkompetuertomografie.
Die Patientin hat auch erwähnt, dass sie damals viel abgenommen hat.
Sie hat die Anlage durchgeführt und hat die Anlage durchgeführt. Sie hat die Anlage durchgeführt.
Sie wurde nach einem halben Jahr eine Kontrolle durchgeführt.
Sie ist nicht wieder zum Arzt gegangen.
Sie hat eine Ausdrucksminderung und eine geschwollene Beine.
Es gibt eine klinische Hilfsleitfahne bei Trombose.
Was fragt man da?
Ist es bei der Lungenembuli und der Trombose gleich?
Es gibt verschiedene Bestandteile für die Lungenembuli und auch für die Tifatis.
Ich kann manche sagen, dass die Patientin kröpft hat.
Sie hat eine böse Erkrankung und hat bei der Tifatis oder der Lungenembuli gestaltet.
Sie hat eine böse Erkrankung und eine Tifatis.
Sie hat eine Erkrankung und eine Tifatis.
Wie ist es bei der Trombose?
Es fällt wie momentan nicht.
Es ist genau dasselbe.
Sie hat eine böse Erkrankung und eine Tifatis.
Was ist der erste Herztöne?
Was ist der zweite Herztöne?
Was ist die große Arterie?
Was hören Sie am Herzen?
Was hört man?
Was hört man am Herzen?
Warum hört man am Herzen?
Welches Herz wollen wir bei der Lungen im Bulli sehen?
Rechtserz?
Ja.
Warum hört man am Herzen?
Was noch?
Was, welche Patienten?
Wann dürfen wir kein Kontrastmittel geben?
Was schadet Kontrastmittel noch?
Niereninsuffizienz?
Ja, natürlich.
Viele alte Patienten haben eine schlechte Miere.
Diese Patienten, wenn sie eine schlechte Miere haben, machen wir immer erst mal ein Herzultraschall.
Gucken, Rechtserzbelastung oder nicht.
Wenn das unauffällig ist, die, die mehrere unauffällig ist, dann machen wir auch kein CT.
Und jetzt haben sie Blutpap genommen.
Was gucken Sie im Blut nach?
Ja, umgedrückt wird es immer.
Und Blutgasanalyst wird immer.
Und ja, Herzinfarkt, Auszuschließung, Herzinsüme.
Sehr gut.
Herzinsuffizienz, Auszuschließung, Prübenepet.
Ja, auch.
Und nochmal, auch die Nierenwerte, die Elektrolyte, die Nierenwerte.
Warum, weil wir das CT machen wollen?
Wir brauchen die Schilddrüsenwerte, TSH, wegen dem Kontrastmittel,
dass wir, ob wir das geben dürfen oder nicht.
Weil sonst müssten wir Blockade machen, ihre Naht geben.
Schilddrüse, wenn der eine Hypertüriose hat.
Nierenwerte sind wichtig, D-Mere, ja.
Und was ist noch, was sind die Prediktoren für den Verlauf Annalungenembolie?
Ob sie schwer oder milde ist.
Welches Laborparameter sagt darüber aus, wie schwer die Lungenembolie ist?
Was gucken wir nach?
BNP? Nein.
BNP, genau.
Weil dann wissen wir, wie schwer die Rechtshärte sind.
Sofizienz ist ja.
Was noch?
Gehör das BNP, desto höher ist die Sterblichkeit.
Annalungenembolie, was noch?
Was korreliert auch noch mit der Sterblichkeit?
BNP und was noch?
Respiration.
Troponin.
Diese beiden Sachen sind ganz wichtig bei der Lungenembolie.
Okay.
Ja.
Und was machen wir jetzt mit dem Bein?
Ja, Phlebo-Graphie.
Das macht man nicht mehr.
Was machen wir?
Du, Phlebo-Graphie, macht man nicht mehr.
Du, Phlebo-Graphie, du, Phlebo-Graphie.
Okay.
Und wenn ich jetzt eine Unterschenkelwähnendrombose habe,
was muss ich da machen?
PTA, PTA.
Bei der Wähnendrombose.
Bei der Trombose.
Richtig.
Bei der Unterschenkelwähnendrombose reicht das Strümpfe.
Und wie lange macht man, wie lange, wie lange antikorguliert bei der
Unterschenkelwähnendrombose?
3 Monate.
Bei der Unterschenkelwähnendrombose, noch weniger sogar.
Bei der Oberschenkeltrombose, ab wann fängt die Oberschenkeltrombose
an, wo, in welcher Wähne?
Für Moralis.
Ist Oberschenkel.
Was ist, bis wohin ist Oberschenkel?
Ja, Eliak.
Das sowieso, das ist ja schon Becken.
Eliaka ist Beckenwähendrombose.
Jetzt gehen wir langsam runter.
Eliaka für Moralis-Kommunis, für Moralis-Superfizialis,
für Moralis-Profundah, ist alles noch Oberschenkel.
Und dann, was kommt danach? Welche Etage?
Unterschenkel.
Nein, dann kommt nicht Unterschenkel.
Das ist die Unterschenkelgruppe.
Für Moralis-Profundah, was kommt danach?
Publitea.
Publitea zählt auch noch Oberschenkel.
Alles klar, alles ab, darunter ist Unterschenkel.
Aber die Unterschenkelwähnendiefen sind sowieso schwer,
im Ultraschalt zu darstellen.
Okay, jetzt haben wir auch die Trombose dargestellt.
Was machen wir denn jetzt mit den Patienten?
Schicken wir den nach Hause, können wir den Norgs geben?
Ja, können wir auch Norgs geben.
Schicken wir den nach Hause, fertig?
In diesem Fall können wir die Patientin nicht zu Hause.
Die Patientin muss monetarisiert werden
und unterbeobachtet werden im Krankenhaus.
Wie lange?
Bis die werte, mindestens die politikas-analyser-werte normal.
Bis die respiratorische Situation stabilisiert hat.
Okay, reicht das aus?
Was noch?
Ja, auch Pynomoniterapie.
Pynomoniterapie, ja.
Was noch?
Was ist wichtig?
Was muss wieder gut sein, damit der Patient wir sagen können,
dass der Patient außer Gefahr ist mit der Lungenembolie?
Ja, herzliche Belastung.
Die Belastung vom rechten Herzen muss ich zurückbilden, richtig.
Und wie sehen wir das?
Mit Echo, Echo.
Richtig, sehr gut.
Wir machen einfach eine Echo-Kontrolle vor Entlassung.
Und dann kontrollieren wir regelmäßig.
Und wenn die Rechtsherzbelastung wirklich besser,
dann sieht man, dass der Pynomoniterapie drücksinkt.
Und BNP-Labor nimmt ab.
BNP wird besser troponieren, ist rückläufig.
Und dann kann man sagen, wenn die Antirogulation da ist,
dass der Patient außer Schneider ist.
Sehr gut, super.
Entschuldigung.
Sie haben sehr gut gefragt.
Danke.
Ich briefe viele gute Informationen.
Und kann ihr alles wieder in Ordnung bringen?
Das ist eigentlich, war das wieder sehr gut.
Aber ein Tipp habe ich.
Bei der Patienten-Wiedergabe.
Anamnäse ist gut.
Aber wenn Sie den Patienten am Oberarzt vorstellen,
dann müssen Sie die Gedanken sortieren erst mal.
Sie haben mir gesagt, die Patientin hat eine Düsbpnü.
Dann haben Sie gesagt irgendwas mit dem Bein, was andere haben Sie gesagt.
Hat aber auch Belastungsdüsbpnü.
Das geht nicht.
Man muss alles zusammen.
Aber erst mal oben anfangen und sagen im Kopf,
okay, Patient hat Luft und das und das.
Und dann das mit dem Bein erwähnen zum Beispiel.
Und dann ganz umschluss die unwichtigen Sachen.
Vegetative, Anamnäse und was weiß ich und so.
So, ein bisschen mehr sortieren.
Aber sonst war wirklich alles gut.
Ich habe bestimmt auch Fehler gemacht.